bill is in Missouri he says my daughter
is getting married next year
we're completely debt-free with an
income of $65,000 how do we decide how
much to spend on the wedding well you
wouldn't number one you would not spend
more than you have in cash now let's say
you have $500,000 in cash so you don't
have a cash limitation I'll just make
that number up okay
so there's no cash limitation then the
next thing is you can look at it a lot
of different ways one way I have looked
at it is here's a maximum for you most
people overspend on their wedding
meaning they spend more than they should
in relation to their income not how nice
the wedding is some people say we should
never spend it with your wedding it
doesn't matter if you have ten billion
dollars if you spend a hundred grand on
a wedding okay it doesn't matter so
there's nothing wrong with a hundred
it's not illegal it's not immoral to
have $100,000 wedding that's not the
issue the issue is in relation to your
net worth and your income what you
should spend so here's your averages the
average wedding in America right now is
around $27,000 the average household
income in America is around 52 thousand
dollars so that says that the average
wedding is about half of the average
income okay and that's too much but I'll
give that as a cap you would never spend
ever ever more than half your annual
income ever that's a lot and that's
probably too much but that's the most
you would ever consider so you make
sixty-five thousand dollars less thirty
to five so you know what would I spend
if I was in that situation twenty
twenty-five thousand max and that's if
you have the cash if you don't have the
cash then you have a different
limitation and the limit you're limited
to the cash that you can put up you can
have
fine wedding for $10,000 a fine wedding
I've been to a lot of them that were in
the five to ten thousand range and you
can you can do all you want to do for
that and there is no correlation by the
way between the success of the marriage
and the size of the wedding there is no
correlation between the size of the ring
and the success of the marriage as a
matter of fact there may be a negative
correlation meaning that the more that's
spent on the ring than one spent on the
wedding the less chance you have staying
I mean that that I'm not positive on
that one I just made that one up but
there is no correlation
there's no all of us have good walking
around since say what you spend on your
wedding is not indicative of whether you
have a good marriage and what you spend
on the ring is not indicative of whether
you have a good marriage if the and if
it's that important to you then you
probably have other issues so is it okay
to have a nice wedding yes both of my
daughter's had very luxurious nice
weddings there were nowhere near half my
annual income not even close and when we
wrote the check we didn't even feel it
but they were nice and they were
expensive but we had the money so I'm
not against I'm not mad I'm not saying
that their little princesses or some
like that or not they was fine I offered
that and what I did in both of their
cases was I said here's what we're going
to spend on the wedding and I'm going to
give it to you in a check now the two of
you go open a checking account and I
want you to do a wedding budget and I
want you to figure out what you're going
to spend on the flowers and what you're
going to spend on the photographer and
what you can spit on the church what you
can give the preacher and what you can
spend on the dress and do a wedding
budget and here's a suggestion don't
spend all this money keep some of it
because there's not any more than this
period that's it and then we assisted
them in helping them make sure they
stayed within that budget to you know
that they didn't spend more than that
because there's no more money than that
don't don't spend more net and that was
a lot of money and in both cases they
enjoyed it they spent it all on the
wedding they did not save any of it and
I'm not mad about that now their
husbands to be wished that they hadn't
spent at all but it's okay they're okay
they're fine Rachel and Denise are doing
just fine it's okay they're fine
it's alright so that's your little
wedding speech let me tell you the
biggest problem of the wedding is here's
your biggest problem you don't do a
wedding budget and I know that sounds
like it's not romantic will whack call
the wambulance okay
you need to do a plan because let me
tell you how you bust up anything
financially is you just wander in with
pure emotion and no plan and you talk
about pure emotion and no plan a wedding
is it baby that's a definition of pure
emotion of no plan so lay it out this is
how much money we have okay we have
twenty two thousand dollars we have
seventeen thousand dollars we have
twelve thousand dollars whatever it is
with seventy eight thousand dollars I
don't care what it is how much you can
spend on the dress how much you going to
be on the reception the catering the
event how much you can spend on the
preacher the site the the church how
much you're going to spend on the
photographer and give every dollar a
name and make sure it's less than what
you have saved for it
otherwise you can have a problem and of
course you need a contingency fund you
need a little bit of a wiggle room in
there don't don't you know here's our
miscellaneous fund because there's going
to be stuff come up you forgot but but
you know get a basic wedding budget you
can think it through and for those of
you that I've never done it before if
you do a traditional wedding the
reception is half of your cost at least
if not more now if you don't do a
traditional wedding that's okay I had a
friend of mine got married the other day
at a very small wedding and I much
larger percentage was spent on the
reception the reception was a huge party
but hardly it was a private wedding very
few people went to the wedding we're
allowed to go the wedding we're invited
the wedding so there's a small wedding
big reception
some people do destination wedding which
is the which is the reception and
there's almost no reception cost thing
because I want to get married on a beach
and wherever Hawaii or whatever they
want to do so you just you just have to
plan it out that's all I care about just
be grown-ups that's the deal
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that your
broke friends think you've lost your
mind